In the multithreaded DAG model,
you represent a parallel computation by
a directed acyclic graph or
a DAG, like this one.
Each vertex is an operation, like a plus
or an addition or a function call or
a branch.
The directed edges show you how
operations depend on one another,
where the sinks depend on the sources.
So this would be a sink and
this would be a source.
And this would say that c depends
on the output or result of b.
Now to keep things simple, I'll always
ask you to assume that there's exactly
one starting vertex and one exit vertex.
So, in this example,
here's the start and here's the exit.
And of course, if you have a DAG and
there are no such vertices,
the start and exit ones,
it's pretty easy to add them.
Now, suppose we have a PRAM machine and
you want to use it to
run the computation.
You start by trying to find any
operations that are ready to go.
That is, all of their input
dependencies are satisfied.
So, in this example,
take a look at the starting vertex.
That one's ready to go.
Since it's ready to go,
meaning it has no dependencies.
We can assign it to any processor that's
free, and go ahead and start executing.
So here, I've assigned starting
vertex s to processor three.
And processor three will
start executing it.
Now, as soon as a processor
finishes its operation,
it enables any of its
successors to begin.
So, in this example,
a and b only depend on s.
So as soon as s is finished,
a and b can start.
So now, a and b are ready to go.
So we can look for any free processors
and assign a and b to them.
So, for example, it looks like processor
one and processor three are free.
So let's assign a and b to them.
Now, when processor one and processor
three finish their units of work,
then that will enable other successors.
In this case, vertices c and d, and this
process will repeat until we finish.
Now, at every step of the computation,
this problem of how to take free units
of work and assign them to processors
is called a scheduling problem.
Scheduling is a huge topic and
you will hear more about it soon enough.
Given a DAG and a PRAM,
here's a question.
How long will it take to run the DAG?
To answer this question,
you need a cost model.
For now, I'm going to use a cost
model that makes three assumptions.
The first assumption is that all
processors run at the same speed.
The second assumption is that each
operation takes one unit of time.
And the last assumption is that
these edges don't have any
cost associated with them.
So let's start with
these assumptions and
let's apply them to some sample DAG's.